[Musique]
la presse quotidienne régionale et les
télévisions locales vous
présentent le club des
territoires avec nous pour ce club des
territoires Marc Philippe d'b bonjour
merci d'être avec nous sénateur les
républicains du Nord ancien ministre
délégué au logement c'est important pour
ce dont on va te parler annom bonjour
merci d'être là renaissance du
finisterère spécialiste des questions de
logement également et on va parler
évidemment avec vous de cette crise du
logement eston face à une bombe sociale
ce sont les mots d'Édouard Philippe en
cause notamment l'interdiction de
location des passoirs thermiques et bien
d'autres sujets dont on va parler si
vous nous en direz plus vous sur ces
nouvelles règles qui concern les passm
sur la loi climat et résilience ah c'est
un teasing
cour pour l'inticction de ces on en
parle tout de suite d'abord on regarde
l'actualité dans nos
régions
et l'actualité dans nos régions avec nos
partenaires de la presse régionale on va
à Poitier où on retrouve Delphine
Blanchard bonjour Delphine merci
beaucoup d'être avec nous journaliste à
La Nouvelle République on va parler d'un
tout autre sujet avec vous vous revenez
sur cette pollution de l'eau potable qui
touche la Vienne
ouais le département de la Vienne est le
premier de France confronté à une
pollution qui est quasi généralisée de
son eau potable par un métabolite qui
est le résidu d'un fongicide qu'on
appelle chlorotalony et qui a été
utilisé dans l'agriculture jusqu'en mai
2020 cette découverte dans l'eau potable
de la Vienne est liée au premier retour
d'une campagne de recherche sur les
polluents émergents mené par la fameuse
Aness l'Agence nationale de sécurité
sanitaire de l'alimentation de
l'environnement et du travail le
chlorotalony était utilisé pour traiter
des cultures céréalières ou viticoles et
sa dégradation dans l'environnement a
notamment produit un métabolite retrouvé
donc dans les captages d'eau potable
selon la législation française sa
présence dans l'eau potable comme
d'autres molécules chimiques obéit à une
limite de qualité la limite de qualité
pour le moment est raisonnable donc
selon les autorités sanitaire pas de
panique l'eau est consommable malgré
tout le 2 juin dernier le préfet de la
Vienne avait tout de même préparé au cas
où un plan d'organisation des premiers
secours un plan hors sec eau potable et
il avait ainsi prépositionné des
dizaines de palettes d'eau en bouteille
dans les mairies pour alimenter 5000
habitants du nord de la Vienne la
concentration du résidu avait finalement
baisser in extremis donc jusqu'ici tout
va bien l'eau est consommable le
chlorotalony n'est plus utilisé depuis
2020 dans l'agriculture mais les
distributeurs d'eau eux en revanche
cherchent des solutions pour éradiquer
les dernières traces du résidu beaucoup
de ces solutions sont onéreuses et vont
donc peut-être se retrouver sur la
facture d'eau des cons omateur je risque
donc bien de vous en reparler ici ah ben
écoutez on en reparlera avec vous
Delphine bien sûr on va parler d'abord
d'un tout autre sujet vous êtes parti à
la recherche des anciens salariés
d'ffondererie du Poitou exactement ouais
un peu de un peu de bonne humeur ce ce
matin le 5 juillet 2022 la société
fonderie du poit toilu à un grande
survienne fabricant de culasse pour
Renault était liquidé 268 salariés à la
porte et un nouveau drame économique et
social dans le bassin Châtel Rodet un an
après la liquidation de la fonder fonte
donc dans les colonnes de La Nouvelle
République on n' pas voulu rester sur
cette mauvaise nouvelle et on a voulu
voir un an après quel bilan on pouvait
tirer de tout ça et on est allé voir les
les fondeurs pour voir s'ils avaient
retrouvé de l'emploi en une année dans
un contexte économique qui est quand
même compliqué et ben finalement c'est
plutôt une bonne nouvelle 55 54 % des
salariés ont retrouvé un emploi et 43 %
ont retrouvé un emploi durable donc un
CDI ça fait 108 salariés en CDI dans
quel secteur alors principalement
l'industrie l'agroalimentaire le
transport et la construction déduction
faite de 16dp la retraite et de 2 he à
maladie il reste donc 90 personnes qui
sont en recherche d'emploi les syndicats
eux ont été vraiment très actifs dans ce
retour à l'emploi en une seule année
c'est pourquoi il demandent à la demande
à la suite de ce modèle d'ffonderie du
Poitou d'inscrire dans la loi
l'obligation en cas de plan de
sauvegarde de l'emploi de mettre en
place une cellule liquidative dans
laquelle figureraient des représentants
des salariés c'est la condition pour
avoir un réel suivi selon eux et en tout
cas précisément dans le cas d'effondré
du Poitou on a vu que ça avait
fonctionné merci Delphine merci beaucoup
d'avoir été avec nous on regarde la Une
de La Nouvelle République la Vienne face
au défi de l'eau potable c'est à la Une
de votre journal merci beaucoup d'avoir
été avec nous Delphine évidemment à très
vite on va parler de la crise du
logement les facteurs sont nombreux
crise de la construction problème de
foncier crise de l'offre locative
notamment avec cette ces nouvelles
règles sur les passoirs thermiques on va
développer tous ces sujets mais d'abord
une question un peu générale Marc
Philippe debress est-ce qu'on est dans
une véritable crise du logement
aujourd'hui on est dans pire qu'une
véritable crise du logement moi j'ai
connu deux crises du logement une quand
j'étais ministre délégué au logement à
la ville en 2005 et une crise des
banlieux en même temps et une autre en
2008 quand le président Sarkozi m'a
demandé de préparer le plan relance
après le le crash bancaire euh c'était
des crises de l'offre on ne produisait
plus assez pardon de logement et donc là
nous sommes dans une crise historique
c'est-à-dire que tout est paralysé en
même temps il y a une crise dans
l'ancien vous en parlez avec la question
du la loi clima résilience et de la
rénovation des passoirs thermiques il y
a plus assez de bien qui vont arriver
sur le marché du locatif ancien il y a
une crise dans le neuf terrible il y a
une crise de l'orfre offre du neuf on ne
produit plus assez les promoteurs
produisent plus rien du tout les
logements étudiants c'est une
catastrophe le le le logement social les
agréments sont en chute libre et il y a
une crise de la demande ce qui est
nouveau à cause de la montée exponentiel
des taux d'intérêt où en gros plus d'un
crédit immobilier sur deux est refusé
les primos acccédants ne peuvent plus
accéder à la propriété toutes ces crises
en même temps font c'est comme un moteur
et ça n'est jamais arrivé c'est ce que
vous dites historiquement d'ailleurs
nous allons redescendre cette année en
dessous des ratios de 1950 entre
production de logement et nombre de
ménag à logés et donc c'est une crise
systémique qui où tout est comme un
moteur qui est noyé et en même temps on
a épuisé la batterie on peut plus le
redémarrer et ça va donc être terrible
très dur et ça va être durable le
tableau est noir aujourd'hui an GL le
tableau est celui qui vient d'être
décrit effectivement il est noir parce
que on se retrouve presque dans une
impasse on se dit comment on va faire
quel levier on va actionner donc les
leviers on en a quelques-uns mais qui
sont pas forcément ceux qui seront
efficass d'emblé donc il y a un moment
il faut relancer la machine relancer la
machine de la construction accompagner
la rénovation parce qu'effectivement il
y a une nécessité écologique aussi que
de faire de la rénovation au niveau des
passeurs thermiques on va en parler et
après il y a effectivement l'accès
l'accès au prêts et puis des modes de
vie aussi qui ont changé c'est-à-dire
qu'on a des modes de vie de
décohabitation actuellement qui
nécessitent d'avoir plus de bien pour
loger une même famille on a des modes de
vie qui ont changé des gens qui veulent
vivre en fait en zone littorale donc ça
crée des tensions territorialement
parlant c'est-à-dire on dit qu'il y a
une crise du logement mais elle se situe
principalement sur des zones qu'on dit
tendu où là vraiment c'est j'en fais
partie je suis en Bretagne où ce loger
devient vraiment une difficulté majeure
parce que derrière ça crée une autre
crise ça crée une crise au niveau du
recrutement dans les entreprise ça c'est
tout un effet en fait à rebond qui est
qui est catastrophique pour not pour nos
territoires en fait avec diversité une
diversité mais une réalité qui est là
c'est c'est une crise qui s'explique par
des facteurs conjoncturels ou est-ce
qu'il y a une responsabilité politique
il y a une crise conjoncturelle et
structurelle en même temps tout est
bloqué je viens de vous l'expliquer mais
il y a pas de responsabilité politique
mais il y a une responsabilité politique
majeure et que moi je mets au plus haut
sommet de l'État j'ai parlé pendant 20
minutes en 2021 l'été 21 je participe
tous les ans au cérémonies patriotiques
de libération de la Provence invité
d'honneur et je me suis retrouvé seul
parlementaire avec le président de la
République pendant 20 minutes j'ai parlé
avec lui et je me suis rendu compte que
son entourage le poussa à dire on peut
avoir une crise de l'immobilier ça va
réguler les prix ça fera baisser les
prix non parce que comme tout est bloqué
en même temps on a un système embolisé
et moi vous pouvez retrouver sur le
journal officiel du Sénat 2018 je je
sonne l'alarme avec Monsieur de
Normandie 2019 je recommence avec Madame
pili 2020 je recommence avec Madame
vargon 2021 et cetera et Monsieur B
minist du logement j'ai fait tous les
ministres du logement et je leur ai dit
att le dernier B je lui ai dit
réveillez-vous ça va être une explosion
sociale et qu'est-ce que dit Édouard
Philippe a à moi ça va être une
explosion sociale donc il y a une
responsabilité de une responsabilité
éminente c'était prévisible et on a
volontairement rien fait sur tous les
leviers qu'on pouvait actionner la
réponse à la responsabilité à l'époque
au niveau d'Emmanuel Macron je pense
qu'on est tous collectivement c'estd au
niveau des communes aussi on voit que 60
65 % des permis de construire sont
délivrés par rapport à à un objectif de
plu sur 100 donc au bout d'un moment
pourquoi ils sont pas délivrés parce que
parce que les lois urbanistiques
deviennent folles de bureaucratie et
vous rajoutez de la bureaucratie à la
bureaucratie il y a pas que ça vous avez
aussi des recours constants au niveau
des collec des collectifs qui
s'organisent sur les territoires il y a
des je là le gouvernement a bien agi on
a mis quelque chose sur les recours dans
la loian et ça produit des effets ouais
ça produit des effets mais qu'on voit
pas encore complètement je veux dire
vous voyez bien la réticence en fait des
mes à bâtir actuellement on n pas des
mes bâtisseurs donc pas ça dites pas ça
un sénateur non je je je sors d'une
campagne électorale j'ai vu des
centaines de mares ils veulent tous
faire des lotissements et vous leur
mettez une loi zan zéro
artificialisation net qui est une
hannerie parce qu'elle est bonne ses
objectifs est ridicule sur sa méthode et
les maires ne peuvent plus construire
c'est pas qu'ils ne veulent pas ils ne
peuvent plus
ur on va la laisser répondre
après répondre oui parce qu'apparemment
voilà je sais qu' a beaucoup à dire oui
il est énervé ça se sent mais c'est pas
grave une campagne sénatoriale demandz à
tous mes collègues de tous les groupes
politiques il vous diront la même chose
ouais mais demandez chez moi aux
agriculteurs ils sont aussi contents moi
je suis en Bretagne d' pouvoir continuer
à produire pour être du coup compétitif
aussi sur d'utres territoires s'il y a
plus de terre agricole parce que tout le
monde vient chez nous en Bretagne et
demain on pour
plusour bah fallait les proposer aussi
donc voilà il y a un objectif en fait
qui est quand même de protéger quand
même no et je pense que là on est tous
d'accord quand même même si monsieur ne
sommes pas d'accord on est tous d'accord
j' regrettez vous regrettez que Laurent
vquier dise qu'il va sortir du
dispositif zan qui oui moi je regrette
oui je le regrette parce que au bout
d'un moment il y a y a quand même une
nécessité qui passe au-delà bien sûr que
les solutions elles sont peut-être pas
évid de première attention je je
l'entends mais il y a quand même un
objectif qui est de moins artificialisé
voilà on se retrouve avec une nécessité
objectif est incontestable voilà la
méthode est détestable ah elle a été
travaillée comme avec le Sénat elle a
été travaillée non le Sénat vous a fait
une proposition tout à fait intelligente
et en commission paritaire les députés
l'ont démoli et donc on aboutit à du
bricolage et je suis désolé de vous dire
que l'urbanisme en France c'est une
catastrophe j'ai fait deux scottes et
deux des plus grands de France la
métropole loise
1anation et on a des Strad des schémas
régionaux d'aménagement du territoire on
a des Scotes des schémas à l'échelle
agglomération on a des PES des projets
d'aménagement dével ça prend 7 ans de
refaire des plans d'urbanisme et là on
est dans cette méthode bureaucratique
vous savez les Anglais en 2011 ils ont
eu à peu près le même genre de crise
structurelle et ils ont fait tout
autrement ils ont fait une grande loi
nationale d'aménagement du territoire ou
à juste titre il tapai sur les
inondations les incendies et cetera et
ils ont fait un circ direct pour
négocier directement avec les
agglomérations les districts chez eux
les choses et ils s'en sont bien portés
on a fait 30 % de logement en plus donc
il y a une réforme profonde du Code de
l'Urbanisme qui passe par une
décentralisation à cru à faire ça fait
des années qu'on le dit aussi ah ben ça
je je partage cette ce sentiment on est
tous d'accord là-dessus qu'il faut
réellement décentraliser et je d' de
quelle manière parce que là Christophe
béch aussi il dit qu'il faut
décentraliser il dit qu'il travaille sur
la question de la décentralisation du
logement qu'est-ce que vous en attendez
ah bah on attend de don plus de pouvoir
notamment en terme d'aménagement de
territoire parce que c'est c'est l'
l'unun des problèmes c'est qu'on a une
diversité de territoirees qui manque
d'agilité ça on peut être d'accord hein
de toute façon vous voyez il y a une
agilité qu'il a pas par exemple moi je
suis sur un sujet sur je je je vais
continuer je suis sur un jugjet
notamment ce logement de de tourisme
pourquoi on donne pas les outils pour
réguler au Mair il y a un moment c'est
eux les plus qui connaî sa situation il
suffit que demain vous ayez une
entreprise de loisirs Unau ou quelque
chose qui s'installe ça déstabilise tout
on va pas attendre une cartographie
éventuelle nationale il a un moment il
faut laisser agir j'ai par exemple à
beauovval c'est exactement le cas alors
que normalement c'est détendu là ils
sentent une tension montée il faut leur
donner la capacité d'agir donc c'est
toutes ces méthodes là qu'on doit donner
la boîte à outil elle doit être à
disposition elle était que pour les
communes de 200000 moi au bout d'un
moment je dis non c'est toutes les
communes qui en ont besoin vous répondez
on s on est d'accord mais c'est parce
que la méthode est bureaucratique et
parce que l'administration centrale du
logement je je le sais je l'ai eu sous
mes ordres ils veulent le pouvoir en
fait ils veulent rajouter de la
complexité à la complexité on pourra
parler des passoirs thmiques on va en
parler c'est ce que j'allais vous dire
Diagnos du diagnostic ubque ubues le
diagnosticque c'est un ingénieur qui
vous parle bon donc je vais vous dire
oui à la décentralisation mais pas pour
refiler la patate chaude sans les outils
et donc ça veut dire qu'il faut
radicalement changer ce circuit du
schéma régional des enquêtes publiques
répétition des schémas de cohérence des
projets d'aménagement et de
développement durable et des PLU qui
sont de la folie furieuse dans un monde
qui bouge à toute allure il faut
d'accord de l'agilité on va parler des
passeurs thermiques avec
plais si vous allez tout nous expliquer
que prévoit la loi alors déjà on va
rappeler ce qu'est une passort thermite
ce sont les les logements classés
aujourd'hui F ou G par les DPE les
fameux diagnostics de performance
énergétique on parle de 17 % du parc
immobilier en France France c'est
5200000 résidences principales une loi
adoptée en 2021 et qui s'intitule climat
et résilience prévoit d'interdire
progressivement aux propriétaires de
logement de louer et bien leurs biens
considérés comme des passoirs alors à
quel rythme et à partir du 1er janvier
2025 ceux qui possèdent un logement
classé g ne pourront plus louer leur
logement en 2028 les biens classés F
seront à leur tour concerné en 2034 ça
sera autour des logements classés e de
ne plus pouvoir être mis en location
alors c'est un cl est précis mais la
crise du logement pourrait bouleverser
tout ça oui c'est ce que c'est ce que ce
quiespèrent certains enfin c'est ce que
disent en tout cas certains responsables
politiques on l'a entendu avec Monsieur
dobress et bien en interdisant la
loocation de certains logements vous
mettez en tension tout ce ce marché du
logement qui connaît déjà des
difficultés on va écouter cette on va
voir plutôt cette mise en garde
d'Édouard Philippe il était l'invité de
la rentrée du MoDem c'était fin
septembre il dit la chose suivante nous
sommes en train de rendre la possibilité
de louer un logement de plus en plus
compliqué nous sommes en train de créer
une impasse pour les plus modestes il
faut déstresser le marché locatif sans
rien céder à l'ambition écologique qui
est la nôtre qui est absolument
impérative mais nous ne pouvons pas voir
ce sujet qui arrive vite Édouard
Philippe qui parle même d'une bombe
sociale à venir des critiques qui sont
remonté jusqu'aux oreilles du
gouvernement qui parle désormais de
dérogations possi au calendrier écoutez
on peut imaginer des des dérogations
donc encore une fois dérogations ça y
est ils sont là les assouplissements non
mais je pense que ça a été très clair
depuis le début c'est-à-dire nous sommes
desj pragmatique mais on va pas non plus
ne pas prendre le point de vue des
locataires ceux qui payent trois fois la
facture d'énergie et ceux qui n'ont pas
un pouvoir de négociation avec leurs
propriétairees en les appelant en disant
est-ce que vous pouvez baisser le loyer
parce que vraiment là je paye beaucoup
beaucoup d'énergie voilà des dérogations
des aides aussi qui sont évoquées par le
gouvernement et pour l'instant très peu
de détails sur les modalités ouais et
avant d'en parler avec vous on va voir
les conséquences concrètes he pour ceux
évidemment qui vivent sur le terrain
cette mesure c'est s nous emmène pas
loin de chez vous dans le Pas de calis
pour pour voir comment le vivent les
propriétaires et quel est l'impact sur
le marché des
locations c'est une maison aux
apparences trompeuses derrière cette
belle toiture et une façade parfaite se
cache une passoire thermique d'accord
les murs sont pas isolés les murs sont
pas isolé le verdict de Denis poevin
diagnostiqueur est
implacable malheureusement pour cette
jolie maison le classement est en lettre
F c'est une maison qui est considérée
comme étant donc une passeir thermique
classe F l'agent immobilier n'y croit
pas quand je vois du double vitrage
comme ça partout un toit qui a été
refait je me dis c'est pas possible
cette maison elle peut pas être en F
parce que moi forcément agent immobilier
vendre une maison en F c'est c'est
aujourd'hui excusez-moi l'expression
c'est une usine à gaz isoler les murs
changer les radiateurs voir installer un
poil à granuler plusieurs travaux sont
possibles pour changer la consommation
énergétique de la maison et sa note si
le propriétaire souhaite mettre un poil
à granulé et il est fort probable que
cette maison arrive en lettre E auquel
cas il pourra toujours louer jusque 2034
mais le propriétaire de cette maison a
fait le choix de vendre aujourd'hui les
les biens qui sont classés Foug c'est
vraiment très très compliqué de de
pouvoir les louer alors bien sûr on
essaye he puisque on peut encore les
proposer à la location mais les
locataires sont de plus en plus
réticents puisque en fait il nous
demandent le DPE systématiquement et il
voient la consommation énergétique ça ça
les fait ça leur fait peur ça les fait
fluir donc c'est pour ça aussi qu'on a
beaucoup de propriétaires qui qui
mettent en vente justement qui prennent
les devants puisque on a ce ce couprè de
la loi donc avec les dates qui sont déjà
fixées certains mettent en vente
d'autres font des travaux comme ici dans
cette maison louée le propriétaire
inofre régulièrement son bien de toute
façon il faut faire de la rénovation si
demain je Contin continu à nourrir il
faut il faut rénouver les logement après
c'est pour aussi mon mon locataire pour
qu'il puisse faire un peu d'économie
parce que vu vu le prix de l'énergie
aujourd'hui pas pour rien quoi il a
isolé le toit et certains murs je
regarde le taux d'humidité qu'il a dans
les murs parce que la partie a été
rénovée euh donc j'ai un taux d'humidité
qui est faible ce qui veut dire que la
maison est bien ventilée et qu'elle est
pas chargée en humidité DEP de vin fait
une estimation après travaux il y a de
la marge ben je pense que c'est c'est
bien en minima pour l'année 2034
c'est-à-dire que selon les échéances de
location la maison va se situer je pense
à une lettre tout à fait acceptable mais
le cas de ce propriétaire est rare il a
les moyens d'investir d'après Denis
povin de plus en plus ne savent pas quoi
faire ce sont des règles qui ont été
édictées par par décret et à aujourd'hui
ce sont celles présentes qui doivent
être appliqué donc ça a forcément un
impact sur le marché locatif et ça aura
forcément un impact sur le marché de la
transaction un marché complètement
perturbé l'UNPI l'Union nationale des
propriétaires s'inquiète et tire même la
sonnette d'alarme vendre faire les
travaux certains propriétaires
choisissent une troisième voix soit il
se rend compte qu'il a pas les moyens de
faire ses travaux et que ça vaut pas la
peine donc tout de suite il va se dire
j'arrête de louer c'est pour ça qu'on a
de plus en plus de logements vide et je
vous rappelle qu'on est dans la crise
majeure du logement ça fait déjà
peut-être deux générations qu'on a pas
une crise majeure comme ça l'UNP appelle
le gouvernement au report des
interdictions de location pour éviter
que ce qui est encore une crise ne se
transforme en bombe sociale an lomer
est-ce qu'il faut revenir sur cette
mesure au moins sur le calendrier pour
moi non il faut revenir peut-être sur
les modalités c'est-à-dire se dire qu'il
y a peut-être une une un aménagement à
faire au sein même de de ces mesures
c'està dire se donner des calendriers en
amont accompagner mieux les gens sur la
rénovation de leurs bi parce que quand
vous changez les fenêtres sans faire
l'isolation c'est pas cohérent au bout
d'un moment il faut quand même arriver
avec une cohérence de de travaux et avec
un échéencier de travaux il y a ça a été
posé je pense que on fera on fera l'état
des lieux hein je pense qu'il y a
beaucoup de peur et de crainte et je
l'entends je suis plutôt je suis quand
même compréhensible là-dessus on voit
bien on est pragmatique on voit bien que
c'est compliqué à mettre en œuvre que ça
crée en fait ça heurte les les
propriétaires
mais maintenant il y avait une nécessité
quand même d'aller sur les passoirs
thermiques c'est un enjeu qui dépasse
même la date de 2025 ou 2028 c'est un
enjeu qui qui va au-delà avec des au
niveau environnemental notamment il faut
y aller je pense qu'il faut y aller en
2025 c'est demain 2025 je sais que c'est
demain après c'est pour ça qu'on engage
aussi plus d'aide avec d' prime Renov
notamment on augmente les budgets pour
aider les gens accompagner les gens pour
la rénovation maintenant il y a un autre
problème c'est que il y a aussi on a une
nécessité aussi d'avoir des des ouvriers
pour faire la rénovation et ça c'est un
autre souci parce que que point
notamment la Fédération du Bâtiment
c'est qu'ils ont pas suffisamment de
personnel pour faire la rénovation donc
il va falloir faire le constat et de
voir si effectivement pour ma part je
pense qu'il faut juste aménager mais
qu'il faut garder les objectifs marphil
debress pourquoi un homme de la stature
et de l'intelligence d'Édouard Philippe
parle de bombe sociale c'est pas son
style c'est plutôt quelqu'un de
raisonnable et de mesurer c'est parce
que il a bien compris qu'on était dans
une au bord d'une explosion et que la
technocratie au pouvoir les méthodes
soviétiques qui sont employées et je
pèse mes mots en ce moment et qui datent
d'un certain temps parce que je connais
bien cette administration centrale qui
veut toujours rajouter des règles aux
règles vont vont aboutir à une absurdité
je ne conteste pas les objectifs de la
loi climat résilience j'étais président
de l'Agence nationale de l'habitat c'est
moi qui est qui suis le je vais pas dire
le père allez le grand-père de la prime
renove c'est moi qui a obtenu le premier
milliard qui a permis de faire ensuite
la prime renove auprès du gouvernement
donc bien sûr qu'il faut rénover les
passoirs thermiques mais vous avez soit
des propriétaires qui louent bailleur et
qui quelque part disent moi j'y arrive
pas donc je retire mon bien du marché
dans en pleine crise soit des
propriétaires occupants qui sont souvent
des veuves sans ressources qui n'ont pas
les moyens donc on peut toujours ajouter
des aides aux a c'est comme le quoi
qu'il en coûte il y a plus de sous dans
les caises de l'État 3000 milliards de
dettes donc aider les propriétaires à
faire les rénovations c'est pas la
réponse pour vous c'est ça ça va être
peanuts par rapport au sujet donc moi je
dis bien sûr qu'il faut reporter cette
échéance et bien sûr qu'il faut revoir
les choses autrement et peut-être
d'ailleurs réfléchir parce qu'un certain
nombre de passeoir thermiques que dans
certaines villes comme c'est Moir ou
bourcoin il vaut peut-être mieux euh
détruire un certain nombre de logement
et reconstruire et donner une offre de
passage au propri aux personnes en
question pour pour y arriver mais euh on
n'arrivera pas à tenir cet objectif pour
finalement en transition écologique et
en lutte des gaz à effet de serre
obtenir une toute petite chose c'est
l'effet colibri par rapport à personne
ne parle de ça États-Unis Chine Japon
Inde Canada qui continue allègrement à
augmenter les gaz à effet de serre je
reviens à d'Indonésie ils vont
construire sans central à charbon dans
les 5 ans qui viennent donc à un moment
donné il faut être raisonnable moi je
préconise moratoire pendant 3 ans sur
toute une série de dispositifs pour
qu'on puisse essayer d'abord de résoudre
la crise du logement et ensuite aller de
manière plus mesurée sur un certain
nombre d'objectifs et puis arrêter cette
complexité le nouveau diagnostic c'est
80 pages c'est pas moi je suis ingénieur
je l'ai lu
franchement il faut avoir fait
Polytechnique ou central moi j'ai fait
central pour y arriver quand même c'est
c'est totalement bureaucratique faut
simplifier tout ça estce que le
moratoire ça peut être une solution
c'est vrai qu'eddouard Philippe qui est
dans votre majorité on n pas besoin de
le rappeler parle de bombe sociale
est-ce que ça vous alerte ah ça nous
alerte effectivement parce que et je
suis d'accord avec vous quand vous
faites un dossier notamment pour un DPE
et pour avoir une prime renve c'est
d'une complexité je veux dire on en
parle avec les citoyens ils disent mais
vous avez jamais fait un dossier vous
vous tombez en fait dans une machine
administrative où il faut justifier
justifier rien que déjà rien que faire
le dossier ça prend déjà beaucoup de
temps donc c'est vrai que 2025 on peut
se dire bon ça on a cette volonté
effectivement de simpimplifier
maintenant on est effectivement en
situation compliquée actuellement parce
qu'on sait pas comment vont réagir les
gens c'est dire est-ce qu'effectivement
ils vont retirer leurs biens comme on
entend à tout commencé c'est commencé
ouai mais après il le mettent à
disposition aussi de nouveaux acheteurs
qui sont peut-être heureux de trouver
des biens sur le marché non parce queils
ne peuvent plus financer leur
investissement à cause des taux
d'intérêt ah oui oui parce qu'il parle
de bombe sociale est-ce que ça veut dire
que ce sont les plus modestes qui vont
être pénalisés par cette mesure mais à
long terme ils seront aussi pénalisés
s'ils font pas de rénovation parce parce
que en fait le coût d'énergie fait que
derrière et ben si on ne fait pas de
rénovation au bout d'un moment on le
paye sur les années à venir quand on a
un bien quand on possède un bien on
l'entretient et on l'améliore autant que
faire ce peu je suis d'accord c'est
peut-être pas la période n'est pas la
plus aisée pour pour les personn pour
accéder au prê donc il faut déjà
débloquer cet accès au prê je pense
qu'il y a un moment où il y a une
réalité c'est que il faut réfléchir
comment on peut débloquer cet accès au
prê pour que les gens puissent y accéder
c'est avec des des critères qu'on peut
peut-être modifieré à terme au niveau au
niveau bancaire je sais que c'est il y a
des réticences parce qu'effectivement si
on allonge la durée d'emprunt bah ça
crée aussi un risque de surendettement
si derrière voilà on a quand même
conscience du risque aussi il y a pas de
bonne solutions immédiate a certains
l'auraient fait après il y a une prise
en compte pour moi du reste du reste à
VI dire bon moi j'ai avec d'autres avec
Jean-Louis borlot pour qui j'ai une une
extrême admiration pour tout ce qu'il a
fait nous avons euh mis un pré àau zéro
très puissant en 2005 qui a donné des
effets incontestables on a multiplié par
4 l'accession à la propriété si vous
voulez euh être sur cette politique de
rénovation thermique et que on puisse si
on n arrive pas à vendre le bien il faut
évidemment aider des primau accédants à
pouvoir accéder au plateau zéro or qu'a
fait le gouvernement il va peut-être
revenir dessus il a recentré le prateau
zéro il en a mis moins ils ont fait des
palabres au Conseil de la fondation qui
est un machin qui sert à rien et au
final ils sont tous déçus de l'abé
pierre jusqu'au promoteur pour dire on
nous a enfumé sur ces affaires et on
sort rien 36 milliards à peu près de
budget du logement en France 1 milliard
de mois la sortie de l'exercice et je
suis désolé il faut mettre de l'argent
sauf que cet argent est-ce qu'il faut
mettre de l'argent parce que vous le
dites il y a près de 40 milliards par an
quand même sur la politique du logement
est-ce qu'il faut remettre de l'argent
ou revoir la politique quand nous
faisons excusez-moi de excusez-moi de le
dire quand nous faons le plan borlau en
200 5 il a 46 milliards d'euros qui
concne la rénovation urbaine et le
logement et au final la Cour des comptes
reconnaî qu'on a rapporté à peu près 42
milliards de recettes parce qu'on a
construit plus on a rentré de la TVA on
a évité les 300000 emplois de perdre
dans le bâtiment on a créé de la
cotisation social et donc au global le
système est vertueux et donc on est
toujours vertueux dans un système de
relance plutôt que d'être dans un
système de bricolage comme aujourd'hui
moi je reprends votre question
effectivement je pense qu'il faut faire
une remise à plat de du logement il y a
un moment où ce qui était avant n'est
plus ce qui est aujourd'hui donc il a il
faut vraiment faire une remise à PL il
faut revoir la philosophie politique de
la politique du logement c'est pas une
question de moyens moi j'ai beaucoup
travaillé vous le savez sur les
logements de tourisme et ce logement de
tourisme c'est un problème de
philosophie c'est le terme que j'emploie
que vous avez repris là c'est un
problème de philosophie à un moment on a
basculé dans un bien qui était à valeur
patrimoniale vers un bien à valeur
spéculative et créative donc à quel
moment un logement peut être considéré
uniquement comme un système d'épargne et
de de rentabilité donc il y a eu cette
bascule qui s'est fait à un moment alors
que du coup tout ce qui était plutôt à
recherche d'un bien à valeur
patrimoniale il n'en avait plus il
n'avait plus de bien disponible donc
effectivement il y a toute une
philosophie à remettre à plat de se dire
quel type de logement on veut demain on
veut des logements abordables pour tous
mais on en veut aussi dans de façon
ciblée là où il y en a le plus besoin et
après il faut changer il faut voir que
actuellement on a de la mobilité 15 ans
qu'on fait tous les diagnostics du monde
et qu'on les a déjà fait vous AZ on va
pas pouvoir
vous avez sur la table aujourd'hui 17
propositions c'est arrivé cette semaine
pour l'accession à la propriété elles
sont frappé au coin du bon sens vous
avez les propositions des offices d'HLM
qui sont arrivé à Nant la semaine
dernière elles sont frappées au Pointin
du bon sens vous avez les propositions
pour simplifier
l'urbanisme Mar du logement très vite
voilà ce que je dis moi et je suppose
qu'er n'est pas contre cette idée on va
on va on va on aura l'occasion d' parler
puisévidemment le budget arrive au
Parlement et ça fera évid évidemment
partie des sujets abordés mais d'abord
avant de se quitter on va voir ce qu' a
la une de la presse
[Musique]
régionale et la presse régionale qui
revient très largement ce matin Steve
sur les suites de l'attaque terroriste
du Hamas contre Israël oui chaque jour
on découvre un peu plus l'ampleur de de
l'horreur de de cette attaque la Dépêche
du Midi revient sur des scènes d'horreur
absolu dans deux kibutsim situé à
proximité de la bande de Gaza le kibut
Berry et celui de Kar AA de villas âge
situé à 800 m de l'enclave palestinienne
là-bas des enfants et des femmes ont été
massacré le journal parle de véritabl
charniers les terroristes sont restés
sur place pendant une quinzaine d'heures
ran la presse revient également sur le
sort des Hoteles oui on parle à l'heure
actuelle d'environ 150 otage côté
israélien entre les mains de
l'organisation terroriste Midi Libre
revient sur ses heures d'angoisse
notamment pour les familles qui sont
sans nouvell de leurs proches le journal
s'intéresse aussi aux otages nationalité
française difficile d'avoir un chiffre
précis on sait c'est que français ont
été tués depuis le début de l'attaque de
l'organisation islamiste 20 sont
officiellement portés disparu dans au
moins un enfant selon un dernier bilan
du kedorset et la France va rapatrier
des Français bloqués en Israël c'est la
Une de Sud-Ouest un vol spécial sera
frêé aujourd'hui pour rapatrier ceux qui
restaient jusqu'à présent sans solution
pour revenir en France témoignage de
français d'origine bordelaise à lire
dans Sud-Ouest Air France avait décidé
dès samedi de suspendre préventivement
ses vols vers Tel Aviv jusqu'à nouvel
ordre Catherine Colona indique qu'elle
travaille à la reprise de ses vols au
plus vite une question comment cette
attaque a-t-elle été possible c'est la
question qui se pose en Israël mais
aussi dans la presse régionale le
Télégramme fait sa Une sur le fiasco des
services secrets israéliens ils n'ont
pas vu venir l'offensive du Hamas selon
le journal cela s'expliquerait par
l'absence de collaborateurs dans la
bande de Gaza enclave laissé entièrement
entre les mains des Palestiniens depuis
2005 et l'évacuation des Israéliens
ordonné par le Premier ministre de
l'époque Ariel Charon et c'est une
guerre qui aura des conséquences pour la
région c'est la unee de laazas ce matin
cette attaque rebat les cartes du
Moyen-Orient et l'équilibre régional la
haripos de l'armée israélienne pourrait
torpiller le rapprochement enclenché
entre Israël et l'Arabie Saoudite ce
rapprochement vu comme un cauchemar par
le régime iranien l'Alsace s'interroge
d'ailleurs sur le rôle joué par Tran
dans l'attaque de samedi dernier merci
Steve merci pour cette revue de presse
merci anï glummer d'être venue merci
Marc Philippe d'bress merci à tous de
nous avoir suivi prochain rendez-vous à
18h Thomas Hux sens public à partir de
15h vous suivrez la séance de question
d'actualité au Gouvernement au Sénat et
nous on se retrouve demain très bonne
journée